[Music]
in 1985
sixteen-year-old douglas casa ran the
championship ten thousand meter track
race at the empire state games
suddenly with just 200 meters to go he
collapsed
got back up and then collapsed again on
the final straightaway
with his body temperature at dangerous
levels he had suffered an exertional
heat stroke
fortunately with immediate and proper
treatment he survived the potentially
fatal episode
and has since helped save 167 people in
similar circumstances
from ancient soldiers on the battlefield
to modern day warriors on the gridiron
exertional heat stroke or sun stroke
has long been a serious concern and
unlike classical heat stroke which
affects vulnerable people such as
infants and the elderly during heat
waves
exertional heat stroke is caused by
intense exercise in the heat
and is one of the top three killers of
athletes and soldiers in training
when you exercise nearly 80 percent of
the energy you use
is transformed into heat in normal
circumstances this is what's known as
compensable heat stress
and your body can dissipate the heat as
quickly as it's generated
through cooling methods like the
evaporation of sweat but with
uncompensable heat stress
your body is unable to lose enough heat
due to overexertion or high temperatures
and humidity
which raises your core temperature
beyond normal levels
this causes the proteins and cell
membranes to denature
creating cells that no longer function
properly and begin to leak their
contents
if these leaky cells proliferate through
the body the results can be devastating
including liver damage blood clot
formation in the kidneys
damage to the gastrointestinal tract and
even the failure of vital organs
so how do you diagnose an exertional
heat stroke the main criterion is a core
body temperature greater than 40 degrees
celsius observed along with physical
symptoms such as increased heart rate
low blood pressure and rapid breathing
or signs of central nervous system
dysfunction
such as confused behavior aggression or
loss of consciousness
the most feasible and accurate way to
assess core body temperature is with a
rectal thermometer
as other common temperature taking
methods are not accurate in these
circumstances
as far as treatment goes the most
important thing to remember is cool
first
transport second because the human body
can withstand a core temperature above
40 degrees celsius for about 30 minutes
before cell damage sets in
it's essential to initiate rapid cooling
on site
in order to lower it as quickly as
possible after any athletic or
protective gear has been removed from
the victim
place them in an ice water tub while
stirring the water and monitoring vitals
continuously
if this is not possible dousing in ice
water and applying wet towels over the
entire body can help
but before you start anything emergency
services should be called
as you wait it's important to keep the
victim calm while cooling as much
surface area as possible
until emergency personnel arrive if
medical staff are available
on site cooling should continue until a
core temperature of 38.9 degrees celsius
is reached
the sun is known for giving life but it
can also take life away if we're not
careful
even affecting the strongest among us as
dr
j.j levick wrote of exertional heat
stroke in 1859
it strikes down its victim with his full
armor on
youth health and strength oppose no
obstacle to its power
but although this condition is one of
the top three leading causes of death in
sports
it has been 100 survivable with proper
care
[Music]
you